My name is Russ Altman I'm on the faculty at
Stanford and number of departments
including bioengineering and genetics. they're paying
me and I have a, an appointment at medicine and computer
science and I live nearby at Stanford from New York originally.
>> That's great. And you are on of the creator, the creator, I guess farm GKB?
>> That's a team, I wrote
[CROSSTALK]
the original proposal and have continued to be the principal investigaton.
It's now in its 13th year, we started back in 2000.
>> Great, and so for somebody who's just seen
PharmGKB for the first time, what is it all about?
>> So we are totally excited about the how genetics
can influence your drug response. And back in 2000 the NIH
and others realized that there needed to be a central repository
to gather all that information together. So the mission of PharmGKB
simply put, is to understand all human genetic variation that impacts
drug response. And to catalog it to make it available to researchers
and eventually practitioners so that they use it in their work. And
it's a one stop shop for the genetic influences on drug response.
>> It sounds like a mountain of information. We have, we do, we
do this in two ways. We have human curators who are experts in pharmacogenomics,
and they read the literature, literally every week, as the journals
come out. They scan them, looking for genes and drugs and
the relationships being discussed. And then put them on a queue
for human curation. This has become difficult and so the second
effort in the lab are software tools to do this. So
we do a lot of natural language processing. Data mining and
stuff like that. To try to help put good articles in
front of the curators. So that they can be more efficient.
We do still want humans in the loop because this is a
sufficiently tricky and the end goal being, it might actually affect patients.
So we're not ready to close the loop and just have computers
doing it all, so there's always a human in the loop so far.
>> Well, who's the intended audience for this? Is this sort
of, opened up mainly to clinicians or science people or anyone?
>> It's a great question. That has evolved. For the
first five, seven years of the database, it was specifically just
for pharmacogenetic researchers. To let them know what was known and what
was not known. Really, so they could pick the problems to work
on and not reinvent the wheel, or be unaware of some important
discoveries that have been made. With the success of the field, however,
>> Mm hmm
>> It has become increasingly apparent that some
of this stuff is ready to roll out
in clinical practice. And so we are now
involved in consortia where we're actually writing clinical
practice guidelines for clinicians to actually
use pharmacogenomics in practice. And, and that's
probably we'll stop. We'll probably go all the way from the raw data.
>> Mm hmm.
>> all the way up to the clinical advice that you
would give to a physcian who's making a decision about drug prescribing.
>> Wow.
>> And that's really exciting because that's
how you actually impact patients and that's
why we do this. We did this because we all believe that the genome
was going to be important for health. And your response to drugs turns out to be
one of the key early uses of the
genome that we'll be able to benefit patients with.
>> So, if you were an individual just a lay person
who had personal genetic information about let's say a gene that
affects the metabolism of a certain drug. You could take your
variation and go to PharmGKB, and what would you find out?
>> You, so at PharmGKB,
you would find a couple of things. You would find
the entire literature on that drug gene pair. indexed as
to how good was the, not how good was the
study, but how big was the study. How compelling were the
statistics when they did the analysis And you'll find all
the individual papers, but what you'll also find is products that
our team has created to kind of integrate that data.
So these clinical guidelines are one thing that you may find.
These require a lot of evidence so there's not as
many of them as there are things for weaker evidences,
about 12 of them where we can really put down
clinical advice. But our curators also put together pathways of
drug response to show what's happening in the liver. Or
what's happening in the effector cells that are affected by
all of these genetic variations. They also write summaries. This
gene is important because, and they actually publish these summaries
so that somebody who wants to learn about a particularly important gene.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So a, a patient, unless they
have scientific background would not find too much.
A physician would find those clinical guidelines
and the supporting evidence. And a researcher would
find. Well, a candyland of the raw, the raw published literature, and then what
we hope are very useful summaries of it to help them think about what the next
research question should be.
>> Yeah. It sounds like a great amalgamation of
the information that exists but in a centralized place.
>> We call it a knowledge pyramid. In fact if
you look at the site, Pharmgkb dot org, please visit it.
[LAUGH].
farmgkb.org has this knowledge pyramid where we
have the raw data that's published in
the literature and then we have aggregations of it, and then we have filtering
of it. And then we have the clinical advice that we give to doctors.
And that's really how it works. You
have all this research that eventually impacts patients.
>> To keep track of how many entries
you have, like how many drug genetic variation responses.
>> Absolutely, So, I do annual reports for the NIH.
>> Okay.
>> And so, over the late years, we have totally
instrumented the site. We know how many hits every page gets.
>> Wow.
>> We know the most popular pathways
that people look at, the most popular genes.
>> Name one.
>> so people love coding. And people
[CROSSTALK]
>>
[LAUGH]
Don't they? Don't they, though.
>> Exactly, it's a pain reliever. People
all are very interested in Warfarin. For
the pathways, those are the ones they like. For the genes, they like some of
the genes that are involved. There's a
gene called CYD2P6. Terrible name. Cytochrome P450 2D6
which is very important for hundreds of drugs. And that's one of our top hits.
>> Wow, and what are people using when they, when,
when you say it's a top hit, these are probably
researchers using this information?
>> Yeah. So we learned a long time ago
that people like the Google-type interface. They don't really want to
do super duper searches, with lots of bells and whistles,
they want to type free text. So, we've optimized our free
text search on the site the nice thing about that
is it's real easy to look at the free searches
and. Categorize what's the average length how many words are
include what genes, drugs and diseases are being mentioned and
we can use that to kind of do market research for
the site. To improve it, because we see what people are typing
in and we can type those same things in and say do
we like the answers that were given when somebody types that in?
>> So, what would you say are, what kinds of tools would you
like to see in the farm GKB side that maybe aren't there now?
>> Great question. And we're thinking about this rapidly. this has been
a website for 13 years. But guess what, there's
these things called mobile devices. We haven't engineered the site
for that. But it is loud and clear from our
users that they are at conferences and somebody mentions a
gene. And they're going to go on their smartphone or
their iPad or galaxy whatever and they're going to type
it in though we're working very hard. At how do
you take all this information and just give the highlights
in a much more restricted real estate stuff.
>> Sure.
>> People all over the world are worrying about
this, and we are, too. so there's that, but it's
funny, the other thing is, we have a very
textual based site. And it's good if you want to read
text but it's come to our attention that people,
even when they have a lot of monitor space. They
want to look at prettier graphics, they want to see networks versus
text, so we're also thinking of re-factoring the whole site
to produce a network way of thinking about pharmacogenomics.
Like here's a drug and here's all the genes that
connect to it. Here's a gene and its drug or
here's a network that connects genes and drugs. And so
we're also prototyping that kind of stuff. So that's
kind of user interface type things that we're doing. On
the content side, we're very interested in pushing these natural
language processing because our curators. Are starting to see that
they work very hard and the literature is starting to get them overwhelmed.
>> What other resources would you recommend, I mean, is,
do you want pharm GKB to be sort of the
one stop shop. Or are there other useful resources that
you would recommend to people, sort of in conjunction with it?
>> Absolutely, so a couple things. we
have this tab based display format right now.
And one of the tabs is other resources.
And its very important because what we can
do is since we know the drug or the gene that
the user is currently looking at, we can have super specific
lengths to other information sources about those drugs, about those genes,
about the diseases that they treat. And so we have those links
and we are always looking for more links because this is
what the, this is the beauty of the World Wide Web that
you can make these connections. In addition to that, sometimes the
data source is so valuable that we, with the permission of the
people who are creating it, bring it in to the form
GKB so we can more tightly integrate that data with our data.
>> Um-hm.
>> So there's kind of two phase of the
relationship, the we'll definitely link to you phase. And
then the, we love you so much that if it's okay with you, we'd like to bring you
in and make you part of our interface, part
of our the way we represent information. And these
include basic biological databases, like Gen bank, which holds
DNA sequence. There's a very valuable drug resource called
drug bank, which we link to. There are the DB gap, which hold
[INAUDIBLE]
studies. and, and, and, and a long list
of other links that you find on this site.
>> Sure. I'm curious is online
[INAUDIBLE]
daily inheritance in men part of that?
>> All men are online and inheritance. Great resource. Kills
us in some ways, because it's great, but it's text based
>> Yes.
>> And it's not super structured.
>> No.
>> It's hard to write computer programs to, to Parse it.
And so, but we do that because it's, it, it is
[CROSSTALK]
incredible valuable yeah.
>> you mentioned that one of the most popular hits
of things that people are interested in are the warfarin pathways.
>> Yes.
>> Now why, why is that?
>> So warfarin is pretty much the most advanced case
of pharmacogenetics that has been studied. why do I say that?
Warfarin has more than one drug that impacts its response and
we actually know what a lot of those, more than one
gene, I'm sorry. Warfarin has more than one gene that's important
for understanding its response, and we actually know what a lot of
those genes are and how to combine the information for more
than one gene. That's, that's a frontier. There are many gene,
drugs for, which we know there are several genes, but we
don't know how to combine the information yet. We do for Warfarin.
So that's the first thing. The second thing about Warfarin
is that we also know some of the environmental variables
that affect Warfarin response. How much green, leafy vegetables you're
eating. What your height and weight is. What other drugs
you're on. That all combines to have Warfarin be the
single best drug that we have for predicting response, based
on the combination of genetics and environmental factors. The other
thing that I should have actually mentioned right off the bat
is, there are something between 30 and 50
million Americans alone on this drug. And probably
or obviously, twice that or more internationally. So
we're talking about 100 million people on this drug.
there are new drugs coming out that are hoping to knock it off as the leader.
But today Warfarin is still an incredibly important
drug worldwide and so accurate dosing. Especially for a
dangerous drug like Warfarin, as you may know, Warfarin is
an anticoagulant. It makes it harder to clot your blood. That's
good if you've had a heart attack. It's good if
you've had a stroke. It's good if you've had a clot
in your lung or in your legs, but if you
have too much of it, it can kill you with internal
spontaneous hemorrhage. So there's this very narrow range, we have
to get it right. And that's where the genetics can help.
>> Right it sounds like thud clouding. It's obviously important
when we cut ourselves and we're bleeding, but you
know if it's blocking our heart that's not so
good. will, you mentioned that there's so many people
on Warfarin. the variation in the human genome that
exists on the PharmGKB site, for example, does it
sort of separate, is it able to document the
pharmacokinetic and the pharmacodynamic pathways separately? Does it combine
them? How do you, how do you present that information?
>> Yeah,
so, we Those are two separates, good for you
for knowing about this, and good for your class.
in the case of Warfarin, there are both pharmacokinetic
and pharamcodeterminants to the response. And there are genetic
variations on the pharmacokinetic side that change the rate
at which it's metabolized, and one of the most
important genes it's called CYP2C9. there's another one called
a CYP4F2 but 2C9 to take as an example.
It's well known that if you're going to metabolize
warfarin more slowly, you're going to need less of
it. And, and if you take the normal
dose when you're a slow metabolizer you're going to wind
up with effectively in overdose and too much
bleeding. There on the pharmacodynamics side there's a gene,
again with a terrible name. It's called VKORC1
or Vitamin K oxidoreductase component 1. which is actually
the target. It's, it's the, it's the protein which
the drug Warfarin binds to, to inhibit clotting, and there
are some variations Both inside this gene but also
in the control region of the gene that it controls
its expression that markedly changed its levels. And there
are some variations that are very important for determining Warfin
go in that. So it's a great story because there's
this one PD gene that seems dominant, there's one PK
gene that seems dominant. Together you can come darn close to
predicting what the right dose will be for, for an individual patient.
>> Even without needing to see them clinically first?
>> That's right, you, it does, you do best if you
have their age, because there are some age effects and gender. There's
some sex effects. the genetics, and then ethnicity You would hope that
ethnicity would drop out. Because you would hope that once we have
the genetic measurements. Who cares what your ancestor is. But,
I must say that our ability to predict dose for African
descent people is still not as good. And, so in
our lab we're working very hard. The hypothesis would be that
there are additional genetic variations seen in that population that
had not been studied yet. But, with knowledge of those, we'll
be able to get our level of prediction for African
decent people to be as good as where we are now
for European and Asian decent.
>> That's wonderful. I want to ask you one
more question, generically. if somebody is taking this course and
they are super excited about the idea of pharmacogenetics, pharmacogenomics,
what advice did you give them to pursue this interest.
>> So, as a patient or as, as a researcher?
>> As a learner, do both separately
>> As a patient they're increasingly companies
out there that are not only providing, so I
know that your class knows about 23andMe. That's not
meant for clinical purposes, but nonetheless, the quality is
quite good and you can get at least a suggestion
of what some of your drug responses might be.
I know there more formal clinically approved testing facilities
that will check your genetics. And then give our
report to your physician that would allow them to that
your physician to make decisions about drug dosing. In
terms of learning more, there are some conferences there's well
I'm a president of the American Society for Clinical Pharmacology.
Which has an annual conference where pharmacogenomics is featured. It's
not the only thing but it's one of the things
at this conference. The American Society for Human Genetics has
a great conference that's going to be in Boston in 2013.
That makes this tape dated, sorry, it was in Boston
in 2013. there are also actually there's Twitter
feeds and there's something called the genetics alliance. Which
is a bunch of patient grassroots group that
wants to see more genetics used in medicine. My
friend Eric Topple in San Diego has a
great course on genomics and medicine that he teaches
down in San Diego every year. For clinicians
and I bet you there are some non-clinicians that
attend that. and then there are conferences that kind
of pop up all the time. So I think
that's one way to do it, it's getting increasingly
played in the media, because people, it resonates with people
very much, that their genetic background would affect how
the respond to drugs. So it doesn't take long
to convince somebody that this is not an unreasonable
thing to think about. And unfortunately, we don't know how
our parents. One of the things that we don't get get from grandma and grandpa is
how they've responded to their drugs in general.
And, you inherit that just as you inherit your
height and your eye color. But that is
often lost in the family lore. And so genetics
now gives us a chance to recapture that
So we can use it for the patient's benefit.
>> So tell me, wave of the future in medicine or not?
>> Absolutely. So, I would be disappointed
if in the next ten years, I'm already aware of
local implementations of pharmacogentics in some of the leading places.
St. Jude's Medical Center, Vanderbilt, University of Maryland We're trying
to get things going here at Stanford. So, some of
these places are already giving trials. I'm I think those
trials will be successful. And then you'll start seeing it
becoming kind of a standard of care. And at that
point they'll be an expectation that this is part of the
elementarian, and in medicine, which would be incredibly
exciting. And then all of this work we've
been doing. Putting together the data base. Writing
the guidelines. What kind of habits desired ultimate effect.
>> Thank you so much for chatting with me.
>> It's my pleasure. Thanks for doing this.
>> Of course.